the smiles didn't last long
from the outset rishi sunak and liz
truss argued bitterly for nearly half
the debate on the economy and tax
what people want to see is urgent action
they don't want promises tomorrow
they want things today to relieve the
cost of living but also to get spades in
the ground
in stoke-on-trent and other towns and
cities across our country we remember
the 80s in the 90s and you know what the
problem we had then it was inflation and
it's a problem that we have now it is
the single biggest thing that all of you
are having to grapple with at home with
your bills and we need to get a grip of
inflation and if we don't do that now
it's going to cost all of you and
everybody watching at home far more in
the long run mr sunak the underdog was
much more aggressive than in previous
debates i don't believe this negative
declinist language is
it's not mine it's your own advice i
have lots of economists that are backing
my plans everybody thinks he's putting
up but miss trust fought back strongly
i'm somebody in every job i've done
absolutely whether it's the trade deals
i've struck at trade whether what i've
done at the foreign office putting the
toughest sanctions on russia of any
country i get things done in government
and i don't just talk i act rishi
sunak's more aggressive approach here
appears to have paid off to a certain
extent because a snap poll by opinion
research suggests the two were virtually
neck and neck with those people polled
the poll suggested mr sunak won the
backing of 39
of those polled and liz trust 38
afterwards the candidates leading
supporters appeared content i think
rasheed stood out one the central
argument which is how do we deal with
inflation how do we steer our way
through a very difficult time with the
global struggle against inflation and
also get the economy uh firing on all
cylinders some important issues for the
next prime minister of our country to
face the global issues that they
discussed but also different approaches
on how we can get this economy growing
but some audience members were less
happy my main concern is i don't want my
grandchildren to be
paying for the debt that we're incurring
at the moment and
i thought he was quite explicit about
that i think rishi was kind of a lot
more cutting her off which i didn't
really appreciate i think you should let
them speak and let them kind of debate
but i certainly learned a lot more about
the policies and finally front runner
liz truss invited mr sunak to be in her
cabinet if she wins
and he appeared to say yes of course i
would okay
john craig sky news stoke on trends